living with her family high above the
ground in the northern tropical forests
of Colombia you will find Shakira a
cotton-top tamarin with a penchant for
conversation say Ola though you may not
realize it this one pound monkey
communicates in a highly sophisticated
language of 38 distinct calls based on
variations of chirps and whistles the
response she just gave is known as a bee
chirp a call often directed at humans to
appreciate the complexities of Shakira's
language let's learn a few chirps and
whistles then examine how their
combinations form grammatically
structured sequences the chirp Shakira
used to greet us comes from a class of
calls known as single frequency
modulated syllables this class is made
up of short duration calls or chirps and
long duration calls like screams and
squeals researchers have determined that
there are eight different types of
chirps categorized by stem up sweep
duration peak frequency and frequency
change
in addition each chirp has its own
unique meaning for example Shakira's Zee
chirp is used when she is approaching
food whereas her D chirp is only used
when she has the food in hand single
whistles also exhibit a unique intention
with each call and just as there are
eight different chirps there are five
different whistles based on frequency
modulation single whistles are
subdivided into four categories squeaks
initially modulated whistles terminally
modulated whistles and flat whistles the
languages quality of unique intention is
wonderfully exemplified by the category
of initially modulated whistles these
whistles change based on the proximity
of shakira to other members of her
family if shakira is greater than 0.6
meters from her family
she'll sound a large initially modulated
whistle but if she's less than 0.6
meters from her family
she'll sound a small initially modulated
whistle now that we've learned a few
chirps and whistles shakira wants to
show off by taking you through a quick
day in her life with these calls while
heading towards a feeding tree for her
first meal of the day
she says a call most often used in
relaxed investigations however suddenly
she spots the shadow of a hawk each
shirt for alarm this call alerts her
family to the presence of this predator
and shakira jumps to the safety of an
inner branch the coast seems clear so
shakira makes her way towards her dad
wait wait who is that ah it's her
younger brother Carlos cotton-top
tamarins often squeal during play
wrestling
uh-oh he's playing a little too roughly
and Shakira screams alerting her parents
to help her her dad makes his way toward
the ball of rolling fur and her brother
stops Shakira shakes herself and
scratches herself to get the hair on her
head back in place then Shakira spots
another group of unfamiliar tamarins and
here's their normal long call she turns
to her family
did you catch that first there was a
chirp and then a whistle this is what's
known as a combination of vocalization a
phrase that contains both a chirp and a
whistle these are two calls strung
together to convey a message the
combination of these two elements alerts
her family to the presence of another
group the F chirp and the distance they
are away the normal long call whistle
in other words Shakira just said a
sentence her simple demonstration is
just the tip of the iceberg she's got
trills chatters multiple whistle calls
more combination vocalizations even
Twitter's yet sadly enough we may not
get to hear everything she has to say
mixed in with chirping sonatas from high
above is the constant thud of a machete
chopping trees Shakira's habitat in
Colombia is being cut down piece by
piece and if we don't work to protect
the critically endangered cotton-top
tamarin it will become extinct in our
lifetime
if the chirp from one tamarin to the
next has proven to be more than just
idle chitchat imagine what else we have
left to discover imagine what else
Shakira can tell us